it's time for my third grey's anatomy
review but for this one
i brought a friend
please welcome my colleague dr luis
espina
who i actually did residency with and he
was my senior resident
so he taught me everything i knew not
everything but yeah are you ready
you have to do that by the way no no no
come on no you have to do it
yeah you didn't sign the divorce process
fine i get it end of discussion
what i actually don't know anything
about their romance
and i know people in the comments are
already getting their bows and arrows
out to help me down
i i just i don't think they're married i
think he's about to divorce wifey
oh and she's trying to get him to do
that dr bailey
harry lamont age 42 is scheduled with dr
shepard for a spinal implant to control
the pain of his herniated disc
is allergic to all pain medication
is that porn porn
as in porn all right what are we
watching correct
go stand in the hall you have to be
sensitive
to the needs of the patient yeah but
that's overstating it
have you ever patient do that no i don't
think i don't think the television could
get cnn much less
look we can't have porn in here this is
a hospital it's for my pain
my doc says it releases endorphins in
the brain it helps keep my pain at a
manageable
level not gonna lie if that helps him
over an opioid addiction i'm with
getting him a private room i
am a firm believer in the what it takes
school of medicine so whatever it takes
to make the patient
comfortable okay
pete willoughby 25 year old gsw to the
chest
immediate return of 860 cc's of blood
from this oh
this hurts he's put out more than 200
cc's over the past hour they never tell
you movies how much it hurts to get
shocked push morphine two milligrams
alex this is my case
i don't understand in this show when
they say a person's lost a liter of
blood
that they're hanging out talking
casually just chilling
looks good his hair looks his hair
looked good looks like you'll be able to
go home today
but i still have patients to see no
no more patience i'll be back to check
on you later okay
you should know i'm thinking of leaving
thatcher
i should never have married him i'll
leave him you leave adele
then when our residency is over we can
both get jobs at the same hospital
why don't you get her meds ready for
discharge nurses thank you
i mean i was an old resident but that's
an old resident of that guy's residence
i don't know if he's a resident yeah i
don't understand the story line
she may be them suffering from the
measure she she may be i mean i was old
but that guy makes me look like you
yeah well maybe not quite but it was a
long time ago remember
we had this discussion 21 years ago oh
lou it was the rain i just passed out
actually mrs bradley verna verna you
presented with lateral st elevations and
reciprocal inferior changes consistent
with an mi
a heart attack so when a patient has a
heart attack as they described it in st
elevation mi it's called a stemi you got
to get a patient
right away into the cath lab which is
where they put a catheter
from your arteries either from down
below or from your arm
into your heart and either open it up
with a stent
or just evaluate and see if you even
need a stent to begin with and there's a
very strict protocol as to how much time
it is from the door to the balloon
90 minutes yeah so 90 minutes
[Music]
you have to be on the table and and have
the calf started i've had a twinge in my
back for a while and i thought it would
go away but then
last night my legs went numb this
morning
my back pain is just too much
miss you we're gonna push on a pca pump
maybe some morphine which should help
control the pain thank you okay but this
is great that was quick huh it's an
awfully comfortable pca pump that's a
quick pca pump
a pca pump is a pump that's controlled
by the patient in order to give them
anesthesia usually there's an opioid in
there
it's programmed so that they can give
themselves dosages
but if they're using it too frequently
it times out and doesn't allow them to
do it
now this is good because when patients
have that
ability to control their pain relief
they generally use less of it
and are more aware of how much they're
using as opposed to when a nurse comes
in and doses it they may overuse it and
in and of itself being in that much pain
can be
just just a humbling situation so it
returns
some measure of control to the patient
what's going on i was just about to
explain that anna's mri has shown that
she has a mixopapillar ependymoma
it's a tumor in her spinal canal but the
good news is that we can't operate
you have a 95 chance of fully recovering
if we get you in the surgery as soon as
possible
you know about that i don't know about
that and i don't know how he gets those
stats right off the top of the dome even
waiting another day puts you at risk for
permanent paralysis
father no
no surgery mr chu without surgery anna
will be paralyzed probably within the
next 24 hours
i hate how they talk about medicine with
such certainty because then it tricks
our viewers here from going into the
hospital when we don't give them direct
answers they're going to be like but
derek shepard mcdreamy told me that
my tumor if i don't operate and i
thought you were between me no i know
but this guy
look mr schue are you taking our
daughter home
anna you're over 18. you don't need your
father's consent
this is true i'm hmong and my father is
the elder
if he says i go home i go home do i
continue to process our discharge yeah
we have to it's insane but we have to
well actually we wouldn't process this
as a discharge we would process this as
an ama
which is leaving against medical advice
because if we're telling
a patient hey you may have a disability
if you don't get the surgery immediately
they choose to leave we have to say that
they left against medical advice
otherwise they can say
we told them to leave and then something
tragic happens right right
it's illegal you'd be responsible the
problem that you have there is that
you want to try to convince
the patient and the family with
logic and reason but also some empathy
because if you just throw the ama papers
in their face and walk out the door
they're definitely gonna leave
so sometimes it takes a little bit of
honey to catch the bees
i was married for 11 years addison is my
family that is 11
thanksgivings 11 birthdays and 11
christmases and one day i'm supposed to
sign a piece of paper
in my family a person doesn't do that
not without a little hesitation
i'm entitled to a little uncertainty
here it's a moment
to understand the magnitude of what it
means to cut somebody out of my life
i'm entitled to at least one moment of
painful
doubt i know nothing about their
relationship but that sounded very
logical to me
itu uh
you might want to have thought about
that before you
jumped in bed with the intern so
scratch my previous piece of advice i'm
going with doctors
or my elders you might want to have a
little doubt before you run off with the
the attractive colleague dr shepard
still here i see
i couldn't leave you have you seen the
other doctor shepard i'll tell him
you're looking for him
[Music]
oh that's his wife i guess
hey i got berna bradley's test back i
don't think she had a heart attack
never looked the changes in her ekg she
had something yeah but her serial
enzymes and darpina means stress psycho
came back negative i
actually think she's
her dobutamine stress echo came back
negative while she's having a
stemi let's explain what a dobutamine
stress echo is so
uh an echocardiogram is an ultrasound of
the heart you can give a chemical which
actually stresses the heart makes it
beat more
rapidly which therefore makes more blood
flow occur now you can look at the echo
and see how the heart responds to see if
the walls of the heart are moving
appropriately
if blood flow is circulating
appropriately within the heart
but now why are they doing a test like
that on someone who's actively having a
heart attack
based on the ekg let's do this as a
patient simulation
we have like what a late 40s female
syncope chest pain negative cardiac
enzyme with st
elevations with a negative stress echo
what's your diagnosis
she's having an mi so that's you would
say she's having it
you're going to say she has a left
anterior arm
until proven until proven otherwise
there's something in the left anterior
descending
however there's going to be more drama
and i'm going to be wrong i have an idea
what's up she did something bad and she
has taku sobos
carditis no she didn't do something
better her husband did
and he's stressing her out and she has
taken cholus that's not a bad guess
broken heart syndrome you're really no
you'd see it on the echo
no if it's resolved no it doesn't stress
it doesn't resolve that fast
are you in trouble now they're gonna
crack his chest in the elevator
really you think you need a strong hand
and a pair of sharp trauma shears right
now
oh that doesn't really happen we have
generators
how's the patient it's not looking so
good
[Music]
doctor and that's your explanation of
what's happening give the rhythm give
the pulse
have you ever even heard of the hmong
people our religion has got rules that
are way old
and away set in stone and way spiritual
and you don't mess with them
you don't anger the ancestors
even if you pierce your tongue and play
in a band
what are the rules exactly when
encountering a situation with a patient
that culturally
it's something that you are not familiar
with smartest question thus far in the
show
what are the rules by knowing that you
might be able to find a point of
compromise to fix a situation
apparently anna's father believes she's
missing something that she needs for
surgery missing something missing one
one of her souls we don't need a social
worker we need a shaman
you definitely did not have a heart
attack
so i can go home not yet your ekg shows
significant changes
and i'm going to find out why before you
leave the hospital
[Music]
so when you lose a lot of blood uh you
become hypoxic
your brain's not getting enough blood
flow your brain doesn't get enough blood
flow doesn't get enough oxygen when your
brain doesn't get enough oxygen it
starts saying crazy
things like you're in the middle of an
elevator that's stuck bleeding out from
your chest from a gunshot wound and you
say you want to go home
o'malley blood pressure i've taken it
three times and
i can't hear a systolic over 50.
so that's quite dangerous that means
he's not getting perfusion to his vital
organs including his liver brain and
kidneys which means that those organs
are currently dying
i'll be right back wait where are you
going to get an instrument tray
you guys are going to have to open up
this chest hot damn we're just gonna
have to get a shaman
today in the hospital shaman's unlisted
in the yellow pages
hashaman is 500 miles from here you are
an arrogant
man no i'm just a guy with access to a
helicopter
cool let's see how this is gonna happen
hey where are you two going so fast
mark is talking george and alex through
heart surgery in the elevator
shepard's setting up a shaman healing
ritual
rock on a porn guy
[Music]
the show is really medically inaccurate
but it's hilarious
it is it's funny she has the porn guy
that's funny wouldn't have residency
been much more fun it was like this we
didn't have to operate in the elevators
we didn't have shaman we just had
patients who had no insurance that we
had to battle to get them treatment
you never shaved your legs what but be
sure you don't cut into the longer heart
uh how can i be sure that you just have
to be sure
[Music]
on this date for the past seven years
you have what looks like a heart attack
no no i know i've had some scares but
i don't every year on this date
is there some significance to this day
for you personally no
nothing what were you doing the first
year the the first time you had a
cardiac episode
i can remember back that far we were in
the yard
i i remember because our neighbor what
was his name
chad that's right he died of an aneurysm
i think and we watched says the funeral
home people took him away
and you had your first attack and you
were close to ted
no oh she barely knew ted
this is taco tuberose i'm respecting but
i'm telling you right come on it's
impressive
it's beating a little stronger excellent
keep your finger there
okay now what that's it
that's it
what's wrong with that picture there's
open flame in the hospital
and why is open flame in a hospital
especially in that bed really dangerous
but oxygen around there oxygen is a
little flammable
well it potentiates the fire yeah
you have stress cardiomyopathy
cardiomyopathy
i have an offer from boston general you
took it to get away
we saw we'd never talk again about what
we had together this reminds me of the
notebook
you guys ever watched a notebook
romantic movie i didn't see
you didn't see it no we should watch it
like a bro bro night
yeah no it takes away his pain
and see the thing is henry
henry takes away my pain humans are
weird
all of us myself included well we're all
unique
and again did you just use a synonym for
weird
in a more positive tone yeah usually
you're the dark one i am i am i don't i
don't know i'm in a good mood today but
yeah
probably because of the porn it must be
the porn choose me
love me
i'll be at joe's tonight so if you do
decide
to sign the papers meet me there
oh no you don't like it too narcissistic
for your taste
pick me i hope you enjoyed our little
collab here if you want to see a
playlist of all my collabs with ricky
ava gabby molly click here say do it
click here
cook here and stay happy